稼ぐカードいっ
そうかこれ日本語でいいんじゃない
午後ね2時か3時ラボが英語でやるんだけど英語でドキュメントを用意したんですよね
922日本語でいいとってか日本語でやれと言われてですちょっと混乱して
でっけえやようなんですから
お寄せください
今日はですねああここでしゃべる配慮かです
戻るわかったすいません
シンギュラリティって言葉は聞かれたことある人
またキーだろうがない人
少しますねー
これこれ元々んですね物理の要望であの愛したいがですね
あの自分の総体3論の特異点というのがあって
放送金なんて-0で割るから降
計算できない視点があるって言うことで使われた言葉なんですけど今使われている意味
は
本ピューターがもう何十年かするとですね
人間の能力をはるかに越えてですねまぁ1
凌駕するという時がやってくると言われてその技術的なと p 10のこと
シンギュラリティと言われています
でこれをですねまぁいろんなことを言う人がいて
例えばですねこの騒動のスタディがあって何年か前の発表ですけれども
まああと何年かするとですね半分くらいの仕事っていうのはまあなくなってもおかしく
ないよとそれはもう法律であろうとですねお医者さんであろうとそのそこでですね
クックしている人かで含めてですねそうだよみたいな事言ってちょっとした騒ぎになっ
たっていうんですよね2年ほど前ですねさらにですねこういう
ですねまぁ非常に発言力のあるおっさんまああの見たとおり
なりですよね阿武野そうするとまあまあもなくですねまぁ受注発表の一つの今の仕事で
その命あることはなくなっちゃうんじゃないのみたいなこと言っちゃったりしてですね
さらにこういう
イーロンですね
あのてスラーヤですねあのスペース x やってる異論がですね
まあええええ入っ家というのはこのこのまま行くと人間にとっても最大の脅威であると
いうようなことを言ってるぜつのアレアレを驚かしているわけです
これはシンギュラリティを想定している話なんですね
でまぁこの
まあ有名な天才科学者のホーキング博士も本当にいまぁ完全なる ai ができたら
まあ人間の宝暦チッチの終わっちゃうんじゃないのくらいのですね
human race も人間人類の遠藤
祭最終
a
地点みたいなところになってしまうんじゃないのみたいなこと言っちゃったリスまあ
我々はを除いているわけです
でこれ本当なぁの甲冑のが今日皆さんと一緒に考えたいことです
でもかちょっとモダーヴするなんですけれどもいやまぁ本当にですね ai がですね
は屋根の世界をです
なんで人間が作ったも逃げる破壊されていかなきゃいけないかという事もとも疑問が
あったりするわけですね
こういう議論が本当かだということです
じゃあまずそもそも今ですね我々は嫌だと思ってもが一体何ができるのかっていうの
ちょっと見てった方がいいんじゃないかなと思っていくつか持ってきたんですけども
あのディープラーニングというですね ai の基礎技術の
ものがあるんですが真相が苦節日本語で言われてるんですけれどもそれを非常に巨大が
スケールで実家の
突っ込んだですね最初のサービスあが5月28日に出ます web for sa で
ruffo ティア写真再建へはわーに写真で連続写真とパティネーション作ってく
れーんですよ
やっぱりめちゃくちゃ早くてですね線万単位の人がアクセスしてどうパップロードし
てるんですね私の雑提携さんですけど
だいたい
人木へんのですね100万羽以上早いんですよ
200万人雇っている会社ないじゃないですか
o 2 o 250万とかですよねよほど巨大な海図
まあとんでもなく速いとでさらにですね写真の仕分けとかだけじゃなくてこれはある
会社なんですけど動画の中のですね物体を認識してそれを超えて差し替えると
わかりますねこうやって方いう技術を開発してる解散あるんですよ
人間がかつてですねてで非常にハンドリングしてくるつのまみれてやってたやつもこれ
の写真とかも
フォアがやってですね
この超高級車が好書アフォーダブルな車にですね
生まれ変わったりですねまぁこんなことやっていとれたりする
まあこれもディープラーニングを使っていると彼らは言ってるんですがまあこういう
ですね物体を入れ替えるみたいなこともやってくれたりします
さらにですね荒野のガンとかの診断的生検してくれてスライド作ってやるじゃないです
かアレとかの判断もですね
あの機械学習を使ってずっとケアし何かあっての後でちょっと触れますけれどもまあ
そのエアに石を使ってですね診断をかけるとその道20年30年の信頼の柄のせいどこ
始めていますおそらくもう数でない超えるでしょうと言われそれをなぜかって何万何十
万って言ってればそうですねえ
法政祭のスキャニングを3次元スキャンかけてそれ学習をかけて組んで人間の経験を
超えちゃうんですよね
カラーそして何百種類っていう細胞でできてるんでどんな人だって見たことないかと
いっただけですよ
でもこんなのは
あっちゃんでまぁこういうのもできると言われていますでできるだろうと
ねさらに人間が歩いてるところで実は三次元のこれパターンとかっていうのをこれ保養
解析っていうのを取ることができて
さあ歩き方だけでその人が誰かって実は今もうわかっちゃうんですよでわかっちゃって
守備はのいっぱいあるジェイソンの87%が可能性でこいつは黒ですみたいなことは
わかっちゃうんですけどその技術を応用するのですねあーこの人
をボケ始めてますみたいなことも分かるところの一歩手前 g に来ていますがこう
いうのも規制と確かにすごいですよねと
さらにですね
これ google glass のあのコンセプトビデオ見られたみられた人もいる
かもしれこれなんか地下鉄かで行ったら閉まってますよと
クエリーを入れずにですねこうやって答えを教えてくれたりつある道案内出しくれる
こういう
1等ケースツっていうのも異常な距離も進んでは素で実際には皆さんが日々ご覧になっ
てるですね
デジタル広告の世界堂から数ツイート件数技術をフル活用されていますですからこれは
あの一件ですね
たなれセーフに見えますけどこれにかなり近いところに今もう here がゾーンが
です1年前に何か
とんでもないパーセントでおりまして8注文前に湿布するというパテントをとったん
ですね
何なななんなのこれと指みんな大騒ぎだったんですけど実際もで私数ヶ月前に舌ねあ
まずなる本買ったらです
かつてすっと前までは
5分後だったらキャンセルできたのに10秒もに間違ったと思ってキャンセルでき
なかったんですシップされましたって言っ
やっぱコントやってるぜアマゾンはですねあのちょっと驚くべきことを勧めるという
意味でやっぱりいいと検出みたいなもすすってやっぱりすごいとこまできてるんだよと
やっぱりデータに基づく系の仕事って相当だ
まで機会によってエフィシェントになることはもうほとんど確実ですキャブになってき
ますとさらにですねあのテイラーてアメリカのサービスがあってこれとかとロゴ
デザインもやってくるです何か自分の老後名医ってこんな感じのビジネスですねどう
いうタイプのがいいよねとかって
自分の月は趣味とかでこういうのですね大郎何十回で選んで言ってるとちょっと考え
始めて30秒ぐらいにはですねこんな感じですね
ロゴを作ってくれるんですよでもうそれでターンまた驚くべくこんな感じだったりし
ですねちょっとヤバいけどこれから多分デザイナーしてこういうのフルーツ勝義に30
キロそこでパ
自分でトゥイークを入れる時代になるのかなと思ったりするわけです
さらにですねこれまたつ面白い事例でちょっとまああの
本当はあのゲームをやらせたいんですけれども時間我慢な辺で飛ばしますが
google のですねあの
カッターディープマインドって会社があってそこのあのプログラムにですねあのゲーム
を一つがやらせておくとですね
あの四時間ぐらいで人間のプログラマーも思いつかなかったようなことも買い方見つけ
てトークとかっていう驚くべきところは伊豆
小江戸とか見てたりさらにですね今まで人間しかできなかったピッキングみたいな
ロボットとかできるなってる伸びてるととんでもないよと人間の熟練作業も機械であれ
じゃやっぱやばいんじゃないのと皆さん思われる
と思うんですヤバイと思うかまぁ楽になるのなると思う方も勝手なんですけどピッチ的
であると
じゃあここで正しく理解しようと思うと age なんだって話になるんですが
よくですね議論されてて混乱しているとあると思うのは deep learning
って何でも出来る ai でしょうという話がよく出てるんですけどちょっと間違って
ですねこれは非常に革新的な基礎技術なんですが機械学習の一種でですねこれだけで8
位じゃないと
本当はえーっとちょっとりぜひ理解して帰っていただきたが非常に早い
コンピューティング環境計算環境にこの機械学習とかそういうです深層学習も含めた
ですね
鍵なデータサイズを実装して
必要なデータで徹底的訓練したらある特定の目的で例えば音声認識みたいな ai が
できるとこれが本当にないです
なので
あのまあ我々が今読んでる ai ですねなんですね
ですからこういうことを理解しておくと実際にはいる今ほとんど語られてないですね
えっと a はいの不都合な真実があってですねそれをちょっと認識する人にそれを
考えた上で本当にさっきの恐怖は本当かなあっていうことを考えたいといっ
の爪はですね
ai パティ組アンドゥですよですからどこ向いたりとかそういうものっちゃ人間が
与えるパティングどぇすねうんえへっ
もう
どうぞ大きな違いはですね
人間なにこう感じることできないけど先ほどだとか聞いたコンソール者ともいうかも
やばい感じなわけですよあの子つか見た目の感じたりですねそれ見てどうも見たようだ
ないんですよこのボトルの持った感じとかですねこの県の書き心地見たが微妙な世界
みたいなものってのは計れますよでも人間のじゃ感じないわけです
ガーゼである我々のても持った
4体持ってしょっぱくのブームないわけではないわけですねうんここ
hati 脳のんですね構造からくる感情ぬファラにです場しかないんですよ
言っていいのかっていうとたとえばちょっと同じ部屋でミーティなっちゃってですね
全然違う今敵といっぱいあるわけですよ
今度は我々読みながらなんかいろいろ判断するわけですね同じ部屋で一か一人
入れ替わるだけで結構いろんなことがあるわけですよ
あの人がきたからこのことはもう過去ので3年くらいの率
事を考えた事はやいうのやめようとかですね高
コミュニケーションが刺さるよねとかやってやるような心やってるこれはデザインです
ね
非常に難しい
さらにこれをクリティカルだと思うんですけど
正しい人に正しいタイミングで普通投げることできないんですよなぜなら殺菌と奴と
同じなんですよ今てキス読めないからなんですね
でもこれって僕らにとってクリティカルじゃないですか一体何やろうとかですねどう
いうふうにやっていこうと甲冑着ピュアなぷれっしょんから始まってますよねを
どんどんいい
これもないとさらにこれもあまり
普通の人はですねあの外で言われたに気づかれてないと思うんですが
静かないんです例えば紙を4つたて3箱になるみたいな事を勝手に ai てずことは
ないです
あるいはですねこれ子供の頃みんな気づいてますよね髪もある別は望遠鏡だって山から
先生の顔がなんか遠くに見えるような気分になるとかこう言うと僕は勝手に気づくん
ですけどこういうですね2歳児から3歳児も気づくようなことを買って着ることはない
んです
さらに新しい全く見たことないことに対して通りアップしたらいいかも分からないです
初めて見たこと初めて見たような出来事でですね
あのが学習することはない何か対応できないんですね
こういう例えば日比谷口に入るとか
対応できないです ai やたんだできないです
これは人間だから判断してるんであってですねこういうことはないんですね
なのでさっきのですいい論が入ってたみたいず人気にとって最大の恭子の脅威になると
いうのは本当のことなんでしょうかということについてまあどう思います
脅威だと思います
やっぱちょっとありえないと思うんですよねまあ今の延長にある ai っていうもの
でなんかに下の行率はちょっとありえないただ ai に間違った指示を与える人が
例えば
いいのじゃなくてジーロンて人が入ってその人がやったらだか起きる可能性それが人間
が悪いんです ai じゃなくていいですか
だがとちょっとはありえないなとだからこういうものは
ですねちょっと今のところ申し訳ないですけどまぁちょっとありえないでと透明ないん
じゃないのっていうのが私の見解です
まあ非情な技術革新が起きる可能性きてしないず
なので a
っていうのはあの人間を置き換えるつよりですね
まあ我々は非常に幅広くアシストしてくれる存在になるんだろうなというのは僕の結論
です
じゃあどうやってですね彼らと一緒にやっていったらいいのかということはまあさっき
の何ができないを見てたらまあ非常によくわかると思うんですけど
まあ一番簡単なのは
正しく質問するということですねでそれが支持になってきますし
あれのですね彼らの機会をちゃんと使い倒してくるポイントだっていくとそれまあ一番
簡単だし使いのは y ですし
なぜですしどうやるのということですね
ただしぷ文脈に沿ってですね
まあ正しいタイミングと
て来まーこういったことをやっていくのが非常に大事になっていくんじゃないかなと
思ってます
ということでまぁ結論的ではですねまぁ私の仕事自体も実際こうなんですけどまぁあの
皆さん自身が
クエッションすると呉市損するなぜ
どーしてそーこれって事はこうなんじゃないのみたいなことを考えて投げかけていくっ
ていうのがこの ai がはびこってくるとかまぁ非常に這う幅広く使われて来ですね
この時代には行ってですね非常に重要になっていくんじゃないのかなあっていうのが私
の
今日の
提案というかです
あのシェアしたかったことです
影響は派
以上ですありがとうございました
オリザてるんだ
ございます